this video deals with the question of how
you can check your data for normal distribution
first of all what do you need the
normal distribution for you have collected data
and now you want to evaluate this data with
a suitable hypothesis
test e.g. can in the test or a hannover one
of the most common prerequisites  the
hypotheses test are that
the data used
must be normally distributed you here also with the test or
the hannover the data are not normally
distributed the non-parametric
counterpart to the respective test
must be used
data are normally distributed if the
frequency distribution of the data is this
bell curve
now the big question is of course how
do you know whether your data is normally
distributed or not and
how can you
check that there are two ways here either you
can check the normal distribution analytically
or graphically we are now going to do
both ways
let's start with the analytical test
to normal distribution around d  to check a data
analytically for normal distribution
there are different
test methods the best known are the
chorus office we still test the chip test
& the other da lenkt
test with all these tests tested the new
hypothesis that your data are normally
distributed so the zero the prosthesis
is that  the frequency distribution of
your data
corresponds
to the normal distribution around zero to
reject or not to reject the prosthesis you get
a value from all
these tests ph value from these tests is
usually simply shown in a table
now the big question is whether this is
private  are less than or greater than 0.05
if the value is less than 0.05,
this is interpreted as a significant deviation
from the normal distribution
and you can assume that your
data is not normally distributed
if a value is greater than 0.05 and
do statistically completely
you can't necessarily say that when you're on the road clean,
the frequently  bility
participation corresponds to the normal distribution
, you just can’t
refute
the thesis in practice, even if it’s not quite
clean, it is still
handled in such a way that a value
greater than 0 5 is assumed to be a
normal distribution
always look at the graphic solution,
which I will go into in a moment,
so in summary, these tests
return a ph value if
this value is less than 0.05, you
are not assuming a normal distribution; if it
is greater than 0.05, you are assuming a
normal distribution  out of info with the
bankruptcy me still that and the
other darling test you can also check
distributions other than the normal distribution
but unfortunately there is a big
disadvantage of the analytical
methods that’s why more and more people are going over to using the graphical methods
that’s the problem  that the calculated value is
influenced by the size of the
sample  r if you have a very small
sample it may be that the
value is far greater than 005 but if you
have a very large sample for
the same reason population it
may be that the private is less than 0 05
let's say the distribution in the
population  wald deviates very easily
from the normal distribution then you will get
a very large value from a very small sample
so you
can assume that the data is normally
distributed
but if you take a large sample
then the pi wörth will be smaller
even though the sample comes from the same population
and
should therefore have the same distribution so with
increasing that the sample
is getting smaller and smaller
with a very large sample
you can even get a ph value that is
less than 0.05 and thus reject the 0
hypothesis that it is
your data is normally distributed data to
get around this problem
more and more the grafis  which method is
used
, the normal distribution is
checked graphically, you either look at the
histogram
or, even better, the coup if
you use the program to
draw the normal distribution
from your data into the program and
see whether the curve of the normal distribution
is approximately  agrees with the rest of the program from your
data, but it is better
if you use the so-called “conti
plot” or q/q for short.
here the theoretical many that should
not have any data if they are
perfectly normally distributed and the
canteen of your measured values ​​are plotted against each other
if the  if the data are perfectly normally
distributed, all points would
lie exactly on this line, the more the
data deviates from this line and so
for those the data are normally
distributed, datatec also draws
a 95 percent confidence interval that is
not normally distributed while your
data, for example, if your  data here
a rehearsal bi  lden and accordingly
partly very far away from the
straight line
if you use dated you check your data
for normal distribution
you get the following evaluation
first of all the ph value of
the analytical methods is clear and here
below you can then also
graphically check your data for normal distribution
check how you can check your data with the data tab
normal distribution i
will show you now if you
want to check your data for normal distribution
simply copy this data into the table
click on descriptive statistics
and then the variable from diedorf
would like to check normal distribution is, for
example, the age afterwards  you can
simply check for normal distribution here
and you will then get
the normal distribution check as I said with the
analytical test procedures and the
graphic test procedures
i know the analytical test procedures
are not actually descriptive
statistics but i think very often when
you look at
If you just want to look at your data, you would also like to say hello to the
data for normal distribution
. If you have a hypothesis
test area, for example,
you want to find out whether
gender has an influence on
income, then you can check
the prerequisites for each hypothesis
test and you will receive accordingly
also just as interested in
normal distribution if the requirement is
not met would you
click here no it is not a
parametric test the data are not
normally distributed and then the
men with nude it calculates the
male user stroke normally
represented data
i hope you liked the video  and
see you next time